bonsoir claude blanchemaison un pays
conviés donc au sommet virtuel pour la
démocratie l'invitation de taïwan la
chine et la russie exclut il ya
clairement un message que veut faire
passer joe biden le message c'est
américain et ce bac et dubaï dance pose
en leader tête de file des pays qu'ils
qualifient de démocratique c'est donc
une sorte de reconstitution du
leadership de la guerre froide et d'une
configuration de guerre froide en
réalité il continue la politique de
baden baden avait désigné l'ennemi c'est
lâche il et pardon le trump avait
désigné l'ennemi c'est la chine hebeisen
naturellement met en oeuvre cela en
essayant de rassembler une alliance
contre la chine qui est réunir est tous
les pays qui reçoivent de sa main
l'onction démocratique et c'est un petit
peu ça d'ailleurs la russie répondre
pour le kremlin on l'a entendu ce sommet
vise à diviser les pays il n'applique
pas le principe de réalité ce côté qu'à
washington de classer les bons et les
mauvais élèves dans le monde c'est vrai
que ça peut paraître peut-être étonnant
ce côté un petit peu moralisateur
des américains notamment de joe biden
oui curieusement les américains n'ont
retenu aucun critère objectif
par exemple pour l'europe la grande
europe de lisbonne à vladivostok on
aurait pu recourir aux critères de la
participation au conseil de l'europe
conseil de l'europe comporte 47 pays
dont d'ailleurs la russie
comme l'un des seuls pays européens ou à
peu près qu'il ne participe pas au
conseil de l'europe parce qu'il ne veut
pas c'est la biélorussie donc la
biélorussie souhaite exclu c'est tout à
fait logique puisqu'elle n'est pas dans
cet organisme mais pour les autres
effectivement ça relève d'un choix
personnel des américains et ça relève
aussi probablement d'autres d'autres
calculs et donc la russie se trouve ce
qui est un petit peu contradictoire avec
l'objectif premier d'encercler lâchent
ils se retrouvent précipités dans les
bras de la chine puisqu'elle est exclue
de ce sommet je ne suis pas sûr que
c'est en réalité ce que l'administration
américaine voulait justement est ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas intérêt comme à une
échelle nationale 1 le préconisent
certains candidats par exemple à la
présidentielle chez les républicains il
y aurait pas intérêt plutôt inclure ces
pays et alors parlez plutôt que de les
exclure oui je préciserai sur tout
intérêt à se concerter avant de faire
une liste dans un coin de la maison
blanche ou du state department et en
effet les organisations régionales
auraient pu être consultées g vient de
parler du conseil de l'europe mais aussi
l'union européenne parce que dans le
fond pourquoi exclure la hongrie c'est
un pays membre de l'union européenne qui
n'est pas sortie de l'union européenne
et bien sûr elle a des difficultés
actuellement avec le conseil de l'union
européenne mais ces difficultés sont des
difficultés internes qui doivent être
résolus à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne et ce n'est pas au président
des états unis d'amérique de décider que
la pologne participent et que la hongrie
ne participe pas une espèce poser la
question justement absolument absolument
et on peut aussi se poser la question
pourquoi est ce que l'union européenne
en tant que telle n'est pas invité elle
participe au g20 elle participe à toutes
les réunions internationales pourquoi
n'est elle pas invité maintenant la
question qui va se poser c'est la
réponse des états membres les 26 qui
sont invités probablement puisque c'est
en ne savait pas en présentiel ils vont
envoyer une déclaration
il est possible que la pologne
d'ailleurs déclare quelque chose aussi
en faveur de la hongrie ou que le groupe
de vie se graver les quatre disent
quelque chose en faveur de la hongrie il
est possible qu'au bout du compte
l'union européenne en tant que telle
elle souhaite aussi invité et que
monsieur charles michel soit amené à
parler au nom de l'union européenne
ce qui est gênant aussi c'est que
probablement que ce sommet virtuel va se
prolonger on parle déjà d'un sommet en
présentiel dans 20 ans mais la tentation
sera très grande d'organiser tout un
système puisque les américains veulent
faire participer la société civile
veulent faire participer les milieux
d'affaires et donc il va y avoir toute
une machine qui va se mettre en place et
la question se posera de savoir si la
france en tant que tel participent à
cette machine on n'y participent pas
ceci s'est déjà présenté très exactement
en
1974 lors de la première crise
pétrolière
lorsque les américains voulaient
constituer une ganisation internationale
des pays consommateurs pour faire pièce
à l'opep à l'époque la france avait
répondu non seul d'ailleurs à répondre
non à cette question de du secrétaire
d'état américain c'est une question
difficile parce que en effet la position
des pays européens n'est pas de
participer à une alliance anti chinois
av elle est d'être très attentif de ne
pas être naïf par rapport à la chine
mais certainement pas de participer à
une alliance anti chinoise dirigée par
les américains alors dernière petite
observation quand même les etats unis
eux mêmes ont rejoint pour la première
fois la liste des démocraties en recul à
lui fait principalement d'une
dégradation sur les retraites en tout
cas c'est ce que dit un rapport de
référence 1 publié par l'organisation
inter gouvernementale internationale
c'est cocasse quand même c'est
l'arroseur arrosé les états unis qui
donne des leçons à tout le monde mais
qui sont pas toujours
c'est pas grave c'est la faute à trump
donc ça arrange bien finalement byden de
m de charges et trump qui en effet elle
avait des comportements que c'est déjà
le gouvernement d'obama qui écoutait les
dirigeants européens n'ont à 100
organisations internationales ont
qualifié dit libéral sur les écoutes
tout le monde écoute tout le monde vous
savez que ça c'est une autre histoire b
pour pour la effectivement c'est celle
amassée trump qui en est fait et est à
blâmer et ça arrange plutôt by donne
pour marquer marquer la différence alors
il ya d'autres pays naturellement qui
sont-ils libéraux et qu'ils sont invités
il y en a beaucoup tous ceux qui ne sont
pas invités dont certains sont des
alliés des etats unis le prennent très
mal que ce soit l'egypte que ce soit
l'arabie saoudite que ce soit d'ailleurs
la plupart des pays du proche orient
puisque au proche orient il ya seulement
israël et l'irak qui sont invités et
puis ne voulant pas choisir entre le
pakistan et l'inde vient bien le
président wade a invité les deux
même si le pakistan est totalement dans
leur beach chinoise aujourd'hui par
conséquent il ya des contradictions
quand on analyse la liste des pays
invités et la liste des pays non invités
et tous ne répond pas à l'objectif
initialement annoncé effectivement merci
beaucoup claudin blanchemaison nous
avoir apporté votre
lisa